bonjour je ne sais pas si la célèbre
chanson la pêche aux moules
vous vous souvenez le petit rapporteur
la pêche aux moules moules
non non j'ai le goût la chanterai pas je
ne sais pas si cette chanson il
d'origine nordiste
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les moules
et bien un font partie des nourriture
traditionnelle des gens du nord
d'ailleurs il suffit de se promener
autour de la gare de lille vous
descendez du train et vous avez sur la
place de la gare au moins une
une douzaine de cafés brasseries qui
vous propose le moule frites bien sûr
inséparables à mouler la frite dans le
nord à toute heure du jour et de la nuit
on se contente pas d'ailleurs delà de la
consommer et en abondance la moule dans
nord c'est aussi une production
régionale et ça on le sait - auront
évidemment ça n'a rien à voir avec les
parcs à huîtres immense de la charente
maritime ou de la bretagne mais de tout
temps sur la sur la côte d'opale
cette partie de la côte d'opale qui va
de du cap gris nez jusqu'à étape donc
sur une vingtaine de kilomètres
ou bien de tout temps on est allé à la
pêche aux moules les moules qui viennent
naturellement qu'ils se reproduisent
sur les rochers et que la mère découvre
à chaque marée tout le monde peut aller
les péchés c'est un but de promenade
l'été
dans la région et puis il ya aussi un
certain nombre de pêcheurs qui en vivent
de cette production de moules ils sont
une cinquantaine sur les communes
desquiens du portel de wimereux d'étape
pas dans le dans le pas de calais ils
ont deux heures pour travailler puisque
la mer en fait découvrir les parcs à
moules pendant environ deux heures et
ses moules sont d'ailleurs promise
prochainement un label
quand j'ai en tout cas pour créer un
label moule de wimereux
et puis dans dans la baie de somme et
dans l'abri de 800 on s'est même lancé
depuis quelques années dans la l'élevage
des moules sur bouchaud les bouchons
étant ces pieux que vous voyez là sont
des pieux en bois en chaîne qui font six
mètres de hauteur qu'on plante de la mer
et autour desquels on enroule des cordes
sur lesquels sont venus se fixer les le
naissain c'est à dire les larves de
moules
chacune de ces corps que vous voyez est
bien fait 3 à 4 mètres et on l'en roule
autour du dieu elle va rester là pendant
environ un an
parce qu'il faut un an effectivement
pour que la moule soient prêtes à la
consommation
si nous sommes à 15 dans la somme alors
toutes ses moules
malheureusement si importante quand même
que soit la production de du pas de
calais ces moules ne ne suffisent pas
approvisionnée la fameuse braderie de
lille alors comment prépare-t-on les
moules à la braderie de lille
et bien c'est à tapis rouge que j'ai
demandé de venir nous l'expliqué nous le
montrer aujourd'hui lors piro bonjour
merci d'être venu piron c'est un
restaurateur de l'île du bistrot de pire
au bout de la rue de béthune place de
béthune à lille et pis tu as un vrai
nordiste oui j'ai aussi cinq ans la
taverne sur la grand place d'hazebrouck
voilà et vous êtes attachés à cette
classe et moi on a toujours été longue
mais c'est vraiment un plaisir d'être
ici c'est le grand moment
bon alors aujourd'hui vous avez vous
préparé donc les moules façon braderie
salir à la marinière bon vraiment comme
on doit faire avec les principes c'est
tout simple bon alors qu'elle nous l'on
prend d'abord alors on peut prendre
diverses bull en principe à la braderie
deal tous les restaurateurs si je
commets mans et châteauroux prend des
moules de hollande parce que c'est un
peu moins fragile
pour travailler pour ce jour locke et un
jour qu'on a beaucoup de travail mais
normalement moins cher en plus elles
sont un peu moins cher donc les
restaurateurs évidemment grignote au
crédit aux plus grosses et ça fait des
grosses koki dans des plus récents mais
enfin et des belles montagnes évidemment
surtout quand des grosse coquille mais
d'habitude nous travaillons que des
moules soit du pays soit de bouchot
alors les moules de pays et 24,6 et
qu'elles sont une chaire un peu plus
blanches à la chair est blanche
regardez en anglais alors que celle de
celle de bush au pire les chercheurs
essaient de moules très très bonne est
vraiment toute l'année quand on a le
temps qu'on n'est pas trop bousculés on
a mieux faire ses moules là c'est quand
même notre région c'est donc la moule de
pays donc c'est celle là qu'on va
prendre pour faire nos moules c'est cela
va prendre si cela qu'on l'a mis à
tremper parce que pour bien nettoyer
c'est cela qu'on a pris pour faire nos
moules aujourd'hui alors qu'est ce qu'il
faut pour préparer les mots le alors la
braderie les moules pour préparer les
moules vraiment c'est pas sorcier
il nous faut un petit peu de beurre pour
faire revenir nos oignons peu d'oignons
émincés plus persil qu'on mettra en fin
de cuisson un peu de sel un peu de
poivre mignonnette qui est meilleur que
du poivre moulu parce que vraiment le
sortant dans les moules
on peut mettre quelques rondelles de
citron souvent jambes et 3,4 ça dépend
si on aime l'acidité du citron céleri et
surtout le céleri parce que seul le
céleri alors là le céleri c'est vraiment
le nord c'est au moment de la braderie
on aime bien du céleri dans nos moules
ça c'est la spécialité est ce qu'on peut
mettre aussi ces types pointe d'ail mais
ça dépend des goûts
il ya des gens qui mettent une petite
bosse dai ont écrasé ou h et ça dépend
ce qu'on veut mais blanc est alors le
vin blanc à l'assaut de muscade et chez
sauvion habib enfin voilà alors la
première chose il faut un grand qu'on
appelle un grand flic a commandé une
grande barre vite parce que les moules
ça dégage beaucoup de volume quand on
les cuit faut qu'elles ont de l'espace
faut que ça assez faut que ce soit
vraiment dans dans une grande casserole
alors on va peut-être un petit peu de
beurre pour faire suer notre nos oignons
et notre céleri en attendant que les
boules 30 toujours d'ailleurs
alors on va attendre que sa femme a pris
peur nous mettons donc vous voyez
salopette
il faut surtout pas que les oignons pour
l'heure c'est simplement les faire suer
un petit peu un peu comme un potage donc
je vais les oignons
voilà évidemment il faut simplement
souhaiter que les oignons et le beurre
fond d'un petit peu pour que le poulet
faut que ça fait un petit jules et voilà
alors on va les faire suer donc remis le
couvert ce principe qui a peu de vapeur
d'eau qui retombent après son audience à
peu près alors on fait suer soit pendant
deux trois minutes à peu près pendant ce
temps là on va nettoyer nos moules alors
les moules
on a fait tremper dans l'eau alors là on
a des moules on a de la chance et sont
impeccables des fois ça arrive vous le
verrez tout de suite en les nettoyant
vous sentez qui est un peu de sable dans
les moules ça sent tout de suite et la
bande et foyer trop tard pour engueuler
cela poissonnière on se croit damier
donc il faut l'accepter lorsqu'on peut
faire si des fois vous à des moules
sableuse zpux est une solution mais on
peut mettre un peu de gros sel dans
l'eau pendant une demi-heure pro quart
d'heure les garder car j'ai un petit peu
les boules mais là on a des moules
parfait dont on a de la chance
voilà alors donc je vais retirer l'eau
de mes moules
elles sont très très belle voilà alors
ça y est de beurre a alors on va
regarder ça tu es les halls d'oignons
voyez le champ de l'oignon alors surtout
pas les faire colorer salut il faut
simplement leur donner un petit qui peut
les rendre un peu plus temple et vous
ajoutez votre sellerie voilà
quand ça commence à suez un petit peu
vous mettez vos moules polaire sa
manière ou alors gagner on les a tirés
de l'eau combien y en a à la voile à
lorient alors il faut compter un peu
près à les cinq à six cents 600 gr à 700
grammes de moules par personne voilà
alors on va laisser un peu pour qui
alors il faut bien laisser de l'espace
et vous versez votre blanc deux à trois
verres de blanc
là c'est du muscadet - du sauvignon pour
être du gros plan ensuite on met un
petit peu de poil juste ce qu'il faut
jamais lu poivre en grains parce que ça
met un peu de si vous voulez ça plus de
goût quand même que ce pas voulu du sel
alors là du sel faut pas omettre de trop
quand même parce que des fois
ça vient quand même de là mais il faut
mettre jusqu il faut compter n'a pas le
sens et mais il faut permettre de trop
et la voilà et le moule c'est parti
alors combien de temps il faut laisser
cuire
alors là les moules c'est très important
quand même il ya une chose qu'il faut
surtout pas faire les ménagères les
moules c'est comme un gigot c'est c'est
pas les clients qui attendaient pour les
moules scellé non c'est pas les boules
je voulais il faut il faut qu' il faut
il faut avoir le nez dans les gens
soient si les moules arrive mais on doit
pas commencé à basculer normalement
c'est comme ça donc si vous voulez il
faut 7 à 8 minutes pour les cuirs flic
le plus vite possible
et dès qu'elles sont ouverts bien
ouverte tous ça peut arriver qu'elle a
une ou deux qui sauvent pas mais c'est
pas parce que des fois ça arrive mais
quand elles sont ouverts tous les moules
sont cuites il faut compter aller
maximum dix minutes mais surtout pas les
mettre sur le côté et dire aux gens de
s'asseoir tout ça il faut on amène les
moules les clients arrivent ou les amis
et puis voilà donc il faut compter 8 à
10 minutes
on va regarder ça alors n'est ce qu est
un petit peu alors surtout pas mettre le
vin blanc parce qu'après ils vont faire
du jus voilà on va reparler c'est
s'ouvrir un peu façon à bagages de jus
par elles-mêmes elles dégagent en panne
à ce qu'il faut surtout c'est le gaz
très très fort voilà quelques fois des
moules qui s'ouvre pas mal grec qu'elles
connaissent donc 8 alors ça arrive alors
des fautes c'était des moules des fois
ça arrive
il suffit simplement s'il faut pas dire
qu'elle est pas bonne on s'est tous les
fois ci tous les autres sont vertes et
que nous d'eux comme pauvert on prend un
couteau ayant qu'on n'ouvre qu'à ça peu
comme les heatles petit nerf est elle
sauvée
manades elles sont pas malades parce que
des fois il y en a toujours une ou deux
comme dans les gens on sait pas avoir
pour une forte tête bombe à pirou ya peu
prévu minute nauroy oui je crois que ça
irait regarder elles sont tous ouverts
quand même en goûter une comment les
mange à comme ça alors normalement
évidemment il ya les les prout comme
j'ai toujours izon la petite fourchette
mais nous on les prend il faut d'abord
sacrifier la première et après ils sont
très bonnes et très chaud et après
souvent vous le prenez donc avec lapin
soit vous nous avez jusqu'à jeudi avec
la coquille vide
ak coquille vide mais je cache pas accès
de moi c'est bon si dans le nord ont
fait bonne chère on fait moins qu il n a
qu une ode au bon voilà alors dont nos
moules leur regard des sens très bien
dans notre petit le petit truc que je
mets toujours moi je mets un petit peu
d'oignons hachés au dernier moment
simplement pourquoi ça enlève un peu
comme ça il ya un peu d'oignons crus
quand même il persil ou tu es toujours
au dernier moment pour pas trop le cuire
et voilà vous allez voir ça alors là je
veux dire quelque chose
le mot de la fin malgré tout regarder
elles sont très très belle
owen jean goûter une quand même on y
siègent eh ben je crois
goûtez moi ça merci au bureau par son
départ ils veulent parfaite alors ce
qu'on va faire
donc les moules du nord pas de calais on
va aller mal à mon avis dont l'époux et
nom qu'on a fait chauffer au pralin au
préalable évidemment c'est pour mes
cuisiniers parce que s'ils voient que
les ai pas fait chauffer je le sais
rattraper et on va vous présenter voilà
on va les savons et nous à 2 dans notre
petit coin voilà bon on se prend chacun
sont allées on se prend un petit plat de
moules à capteur de muscade et voilà
[Musique]